well isn't this a fun award season for
you miss thing I know you became the it
girl first of all what does this mean to
you to be here tonight now you have an
Oscar nomination another one during this
very special role well what is really
special about tonight for me is its peer
to peer its actors nominating and voting
for their fellow actors and to me
there's nothing better than that a lot
of people are sitting back that we
talked to about your wins at the Golden
Globes and other things have said you
know it's her time she deserves this
this these awards are amazing the wife
was amazing but she deserves this for
her career span and everything she's
given us what do you make of that well
it's lovely
there was a very interesting article in
the LA Times about I that it should be
for my work and the wife you know it's
which I really I really that really
meant a lot to me I guess you know
having been in this business for almost
45 years people are bound to look back
and the fact that it's my work is still
resonating with people that's that's
what it's all about so that means the
most to me but you're a showstopper in
the wife this is a show-stopping role
what does the Oscar nomination mean it
means a lot it really really really
means a lot especially for this kind of
world that's so internal you know so
Michael Douglas is here tonight for
Kaminsky mess it see I'm live hey guys
can't speak it's so beautiful Michael
Douglas is here it's been 30 years since
you guys work together on fatal
attraction what do you make of that is
it cool to see your own buddies out and
always cool to see Michael what do you
remember of that time oh of when we were
making the movie it was pretty intense
it was fun I was intimidated by Michael
at first he was so like Hollywood and he
had such a you know he knew all the best
hotels and all that kind of thing and
but by that when we started working
together we really really got on and we
really understood each other and and
also there's a risk together I want to
show you something my producer just
handed me that you posted today what do
you think of this like I don't know
where that came from but I love it
that is fierce that's you mama well it's
like it's like the character I played on
the shield only now she doesn't miss she
you know who else is here tonight is
Emma Stone and there's rumors that she's
gonna be korilla de Vil have you talked
to her about it she asked for advice I
haven't I would you know I don't think
it's me to go to her I you know I don't
know what advice I could possibly give
them a snow evil yeah yeah last thing I
want to know this suit your hands down
so fabulous what are you wearing it's
it's custom Ralph Lauren it has 230,000
little crystals yeah no big deal
wonderful car to Mike you're so stunning
good luck tonight and good luck of the
Oscars and we just love you and you
deserve it all
[Music]